But not berries are good to eat when you have cancer, but Gerson says no to berries.
What are your thoughts because I have been on a lot of berries? I was not listed on my list of
not to eat from you or my RGCC doctor. Well, a lot of berries can be very high in antioxidants
again, so berries have a lot of good benefits to them. Now berries also have sugar,
can raise your glucose levels. That's why getting a glucometer or just checking your
glucose levels can be a good thing to do. You could go to Target or Walgreens or something like that
and buy a glucometer for a really cheap. You always want to check that in a fasting state.
Now on the member's site, I actually have a form you could download to measure your glucose
on a regular basis. You always want to do that in a fasting state, so typically you do that when you
wake up in the morning. You measure your glucose. The goal is really to get your glucose around 75,
80. That's really what you want to do. And if berries are spiky, so again, we could talk an hour
about this because some people can eat some carbohydrates and it really does very little to their
blood glucose. Some people can eat just a little bit of carbohydrates and their blood glucose
just spikes through the roof. Why is that? Because it has to do with how damaged your cells are the
insulin receptors on your cells. So your glucose level has a lot to do with your diet,
but it has even more to do with the health of your cells, your cell membranes in particular.
Also, the health of your paycrease itself because your paycrease part of your paycrease makes
insulin. But if a person, let's say, doesn't have an issue with that part of the paycrease,
they do not have type 1 diabetes, which is an autoimmune disease on the island cells in the paycrease
that make insulin to say they do not have that. And they have issues of getting their glucose levels
down. Then it's really a cell membrane issue. I just talked to somebody the other day that said
that they eat really super healthy and they actually went on a keto diet and they were doing really
good on their keto diet. They did it for three months. They did really well. They went off their
keto diet and they're still eating super, super clean. This is actually a fairly young person,
but they noticed that their glucose levels spiked. And I said, well, one of them, she said,
I can't really get them down now. It's been months. One of them, they're in the 200s range.
Holy cow, that's not good. So I said, you immediately have to get in and get checked. My suspect
is that this, that a ketogenic diet actually sparked an autoimmune attack on the paycrease
of this person as type 1 diabetes now. I don't think it's type 2 diabetes. I think it's type 1.
So the difference between type 1 and diabetes and type 2 is type 1 is an autoimmune disease.
On the paycrease type 2 is just damage cell receptor sites. So totally different,
it should be called something different, but both result in elevated glucose levels.
So maybe too much information, but it really depends on your glucose levels ultimately.
But in general, I disagree with Max Gerson. I think that berries have much benefit. Now,
if you're drinking juice like grape juice or raspberry juice, I don't know, there's raspberry juice,
but that is, you're just getting the sugar, you're not really getting the benefit. If you eat the whole
food, it's huge benefits of the whole food and the synergistic nutrients that are in that food
that we haven't even discovered yet. So eating the whole berries has lots of benefits. But
to really make sure, getting a glucose columnar and checking your glucose
levels would be the way to go.